about
[Music]
thank you
and there is a silence
thanks so much Omar um hi everyone my
name is Emily black I'm a postdoc at
Samford University working at reglab
with Daniel ho thank you so much for
having me here today I'm going to talk
to you a little bit about fairness and
unfairness Beyond multi-calibration I'm
going to talk about all of the choices
that we have that we that we have the
option to make when we're building a
machine learning model and how we can
leverage those choices to mitigate
unfairness and machine learning
so
um a lot of us have probably seen
fairness papers that go something like
this we have a model and some prediction
tasks we have some notion of fairness
that maybe we've defined and we can
strain a model to satisfy that fairness
definition and that's wonderful that's
excellent it leads to sort of
transferable situation um solutions to
fairness problems across a variety of
models and application tasks but what do
we do when this doesn't work super well
in practice and is this the main tool
that we have in our toolbox to mitigate
unfair behavior on the ground
um well there's kind of a lot going on
underneath the hood when we make a
machine learning model we have a lot of
decisions to make everything from what a
model's prediction Target should be when
we're trying to sort of approximate a
predictable task from a policy or
business one we have all the little
steps that we take turning the data that
we're given into stuff that a model can
understand through feature engineering
uh even the hyper parameters that we
have on the model and this can all
authentically affect um
fairness Behavior so while we most often
intervene on say the optimization
procedure or the prediction procedure
ostensibly we could choose kind of any
choice that we make within the machine
learning pipeline the model building
process to make fairer models
and there's been a lot of work recently
showing that these choices do have a
huge impact on Model Behavior and
specifically on fairness Behavior so
some of you may have heard about this
really famous paper that came out
recently from Ziad obermeyer at all
about how switching the prediction task
in a healthcare distribution model so a
model that was allocating Healthcare in
a population you could reduce the racial
bias and the predictions of that model
by changing the prediction task from
something that was effect essentially
predicting how expensive that person's
health care needs would be to something
that was differently correlated with
health and that ended up reducing racial
bias by quite a lot a paper that I'm
going to talk about in this presentation
is how in IRS tax audit models so
choosing who is audited by the IRS you
can reduce the kind of over burdensome
amounts of audits on lower income
individuals by switching the prediction
Target
um in that situation as well so I'll go
in more into that later but even smaller
changes in the model building process
like how you pre-process your data have
also been shown to have huge fairness
impact so there's this interesting paper
by 801 from the University of Zurich
that shows that uh if you you know
there's often this talk about
differences in accuracy and translation
across different languages and MLP
models what she shows is that um if you
you can mitigate this at least partially
and substantially by making sure that
the size of the smallest unit of
language that's going into these models
is the same across all languages so you
have some models that you have some
languages with longer words some
languages with shorter words if you chop
up the words inside uh languages with
longer words you actually can mitigate
some of the translation
um accuracy differences across models
and even you know tiny changes like
changes to model hyper parameters can
also impact Model Behavior pretty
substantially this doesn't just happen
in predictions as has been shown for
example by Marx at all but also in a
model's internal so it's you know how a
prediction is made so this paper from
iclr last year uh selective ensembles
for consistent predictions in the
beginning shows how even if you just
change a deep model's random seed the
top feature is that it relies upon to
make a prediction for a given Point can
actually change somewhat substantially
um so you know with all of this in mind
given that there's so many decisions to
make and they seem to have such a huge
impact on Model Behavior a natural
question to ask maybe is how can we
leverage the choices that we make along
the pipeline to change model fairness
behavior and what are the repercussions
of the freedom that the all these
choices allow us foreign
and I'm going to attempt to start to
answer these questions by talking to you
guys about two papers um and the first
I'm talking about an example of
leveraging higher order changes to the
modeling pipeline so changing the
prediction Target and IRS tax income
models and how this can impact fairness
with respect to income
um and then the second paper I'm going
to talk about just the situation where
say you're like okay Emily I can't
change my whole gosh darn model I
already have my prediction Target I
already have most of my data
well even when you have your prediction
Target set and your data set and maybe
you can't even change your model's
accuracy that much for the sake of
fairness even in that situation we still
have a lot of flexibility to have models
with different fairness behaviors and
there are it's even easier actually in
that situation to tie the fact that you
do have flexibility and freedom to
repercussions in the law so I'm going to
show how some
something called the disparate impact
Doctrine uh
interacts with some of the freedom that
we have along the machine learning
pipeline and you know while I'm gonna
show you two examples of papers that
talk about sort of how we can leverage
the pipeline and the repercussions of
the choices that we have along that
pipeline I hope what you'll take away
from this talk you know if if you take
away anything is uh just how much
Freedom we really do have when making
machine learning models
um and how uh we could we should
hopefully look into leveraging more of
these choices to make uh Fair models as
we continue to make more and more models
and more and more places
um
okay but first as promised I'll talk
about the IRS so in this project through
a novel collaboration with the um uh
Internal Revenue Service and Stanford we
are investigating the use of AI and ml
systems in the tax audit selection
process so who the Internal Revenue
Service is selecting to investigate
their tax returns because they think
that there was something done wrong on
their taxes and we focus in particular
on investigating
um fairness of AI selected audit
allocations with respect to taxpayer
income
and in order to investigate fairness
with respect to taxpayer income we sort
of found that a lot of the common
fairness definitions and desiderata
didn't fit quite exactly with what we
wanted
um and also if you're taking into
account IRS buy-in there was you know
maybe a little bit of discussions about
you know what's the right thing to do
and all this stuff so instead of um
using some of the more sort of common
fairness definitions we relied upon this
notion from the Public Finance
literature called vertical equity which
is centered around treating different
people appropriately differently to
achieve fairness I'll go into that
briefly a little bit later but what we
find basically is that off-the-shelf
fairness mitigation methods don't always
function so well in public policy
context especially because of the fact
that in this situation where we have a
budgeted allocation problem so some of
the mitigation techniques that are
common in the literature sort of deal
with the whole model and not the fact
that you might only be using small
software
Beyond sort of the conceptual
differences with what we hope for
behaviorally from the model and what we
find instead is that by changing some of
the modeling decisions that we've made
along the way when building an IRS tax
audit model namely changing the
prediction Target from predicting binary
whether or not someone is likely to
misreport to the expected value of how
much they are likely to misreport on
their taxes that ends up being arguably
a more effective method of mitigating
unfair Behavior with respect to income
but first i'm going to talk about some
background on IRS data how tax audits
work and like the IRS in general then
I'm going to give you some motivating
facts based off of that data that we
have access to about how audits work
right now and how they may or may not be
unfair I'll briefly describe the audit
problem and then I'll talk a little bit
about vertical equity and how we sort of
conceptualize that and then some results
before I move on to my discussion of
model multiplication
so taxes fund the US government but tax
collection doesn't always work perfectly
the estimated tax Gap yearly is about
450 billion dollars which is about 20 of
all income tax liability and um just in
case I'm sorry if I didn't cover this
earlier but the IRS is the Internal
Revenue Service that's the agency and
the government that collects people's
taxes that they pay
um so that's good with everyone awesome
okay
um so uh there's a 450 billion dollars
ah there's a there's 20 of all income
tax liability in this project we're just
working with individual income tax so
we're not thinking about businesses or
anything like that
um
so in order to recover lost revenue and
to deter non-compliance with the tax
code the IRS audits individuals so they
look into the tax forms that they think
are not compliant with the tax code but
how these audits can proceed differ
based on where you sit on the income
Spectrum so if you're on the higher end
of the income Spectrum if you have more
money you're likely to get a request for
excess tax liability after an
investigation has taken place
um however if you're on the lower end of
the income Spectrum the IRS is most
likely auditing you for uh supposedly
falsely claiming a tax credit and so
they will send you a letter saying we
don't think that you deserve this tax
credit and we're just not going to give
you the money and the onerous is on the
taxpayer to prove that they deserve that
tax credit so how the audit proceeds is
a little bit different
um audits can pose a heavy burden on
individuals and can even lead to
financial hardship a report from the
national taxpayer Advocate said that
this is particularly true for low-income
individuals as they can rely on tax
refunds for rent payments car payments
Etc and so given the high-stakes nature
of IRS tax audits it's important that we
find an allocation system that
distributes audits equally with respect
to taxpayer income and that's what we're
hoping to do here
um so with all of this in mind it's sort
of the question that I'm approaching in
this first project is how can we make a
machine learning based audit selection
system as Fair as possible big asterisk
given institutional constraints with
respect to an individual's income and
what tools can we leverage yes why do
you want to allocate them equally
well we're not going to allocate them
equally not at all
coming from higher income
let me yes definitely I apologize if
that was the impression that I gave I
mean fairly but definitely not equally
um yeah can you also just explain one
more time how the two different audits
work yeah so
um
is very helpful but basically when
you're on the higher end of the income
Spectrum uh the IRS will do an
investigation first usually one where
they will uh either send out an auditor
to you or like have an auditor
correspond with you in some way
um and they won't kind of uh request the
external funds until they've already
kind of proven that you um owe more
money meanwhile if you're on the lower
end of the income spectrum and you're
claiming a tax credit so you're saying
like hey you know uh I make under the
income cap for the Earned Income Tax
Credit that's an income subsidy for
Working Families uh I think I should get
like a six thousand dollar tax refund
from the IRS the IRS will be like ah it
doesn't look like you qualify send you a
letter saying that doesn't look like you
qualify
um and then won't send you the tax
refund and then it's on you to basically
say like no I really do deserve this
credit
yes
the credit refunds are different from
the non-credit refunds it just so
happens that most people claiming tax
credits are on the lower end of the
income Spectrum especially so especially
the tax credits that they pay the most
attention to so the biggest tax credits
like the Earned Income Tax Credit are on
the lower end of the income spectrum and
so that's why this is
whether you own doctors or or requesting
their refund or is it just related to
whether the audit is about the tax
credit or about the income that you
that's a good question I know that
they've particularly pay attention to
the Earned Income Tax Credit in
particular I haven't heard about
um whether or not you're getting money
back or or paying money in general I
know that it's centered around
especially their own income tax credit
in the interest of time do you mind if
like okay great
um
all right so this is the question that
I'm sort of tackling uh what tools can
we leverage to make a machine gun system
as
um Fair as possible given institutional
constraints so to answer these questions
uh I get to look at real IRS tax data
anonymized of course
um so I have two data sets the national
research program data which is oh my
gosh I can't believe a random sample a
statistical random sample that the IRS
collects on a yearly basis they use it
to estimate the tax Gap we use it for
research purposes so we don't have to
worry about selection bias when we're
doing these experiments and then there's
also operational audits these are risk
selected audits um I have them from
actually 2010 to 2014 as well and these
are audits that are selected and have
been done to actually recover the tax
Gap over the last several years so yes
random sample it's like they randomly
audited 70 000 people they randomly
audited 70 000 people exactly
um
and so both of these data sets
essentially look the same you just know
which one is which because you need to
know which one is the random sampling
which isn't and each row is just an
individual person's tax return
anonymized
um and then also the result of the audit
so that they were audited and how much
money they owed if they owed money at
all
every audits that the first thing about
it is
so they they would uh that's a good
question they would um
so actually it probably is both
that's a good question if they did
correspondence audits in the random
sample I know that they have the same
kind of examiner look over each person's
tax returns and then decide oh my god do
they owe money or not and then they
would pursue the audit um if they did in
fact owe money so they would probably
take whichever
um method was the method that would use
for that particular type of so second
tax fraud but I'm not entirely sure
that's a good question
um so we use the NRP data to train all
of our machine learning models uh but we
use operational data to investigate the
status quo of IRS tax audit Behavior
which I'm going to talk to you a little
bit about really briefly now
um so here we have a graph of the IRS
audit rate by income in 2014 the y-axis
is audit rate and the x-axis is income
in thousands so each point on this line
is a bucket of ten thousand people sorry
a bucket of people that make between uh
you know zero and ten thousand dollars
10 and 20 Etc so this is a million over
here
um and uh what we can see here uh I'm
going to talk about two sort of
motivating facts here
um firstly is that at least in most
recent years very low-income individuals
and high income individuals are audited
at the same rate so we can see here
people making
um above around fifty thousand dollars
or below fifty thousand dollars and
between seven hundred thousand and a
million dollars here depending on where
you hit this bumpy line
um are audited at the same rate and
everyone in between is audited at a
lower rate and I'll just say really
quickly
um this also transfers over to when we
plot this graph in terms of income
deciles so that last graph was in terms
of income buckets of ten thousand
dollars this is uh ten percentiles of
income with the lower
with the number here being the lower
bound of income on each of those
percentiles so this is a zero to Tenth
the 10th the 20th Etc
um and so what we can see is that that
Spike that looks small in that first
graph actually makes up a large portion
of the U.S population
um
and however you know that's maybe bad
enough but if we look about if we look
at actual tax non-compliance as a
function of income again this is income
deathile uh this is non-compliance over
two hundred dollars
um so like whether or not someone missed
reports on their taxes above 200 we see
that non-compliance actually increases
roughly monotonically in income so these
two facts together sort of bring us to
uh oh sorry yeah the x-axis here again
was the uh income deciles with the
income on the bottom end of the decile
and then the y-axis was the Miss report
rate um the percentage of the population
that's missed reporting over two hundred
dollars
um and these two facts together leads to
sort of a motivating question of how
we'll understand equity in this context
if misreporting increases monotonically
in income why is there such a focus on
the lower end of the income factor is
this when you say income is this sort of
the verified post audit income or the
pre the reported this is adjusted gross
income post audit post audit so I would
have guessed the spike was because
if you don't report any income that's
very suspicious yeah no this is because
I don't wanna
I can actually I'm not going to talk
about the fact that it's uh about this
too too much in this presentation so I'm
happy to talk about this more offline
but basically audits on the low end of
the income Spectrum are very cheap
and the return on investment is almost
unbeatable
um so if you are in a resource
constrained IRS you don't have that much
money your budget's been decreasing year
to year the best way the most sure way
to make sure you're getting
um millions of dollars back is actually
by targeting low income individuals
especially because you know it's a
letter instead of sending out a person
right and then also they have this rule
that if you don't respond to that letter
that's taken into the mission of
non-compliance and they won't send you
the money so you have all these
low-income people who maybe yeah make
sure
then is the 50th what's in this figure
or the zero perfect
yeah so
Chris this is percent of the internet
this report percent of returns that have
any amount of difference percent of
returns that have over two hundred
dollars in support it yes
um no no no no problem
um I'm glad that you guys have questions
this is great
um okay so I'll quickly Define the audit
problem before moving on to our
understanding of equity in this context
so uh the IRS has many many many
objectives that it wants to accomplish
when it's making an audit allocation
they want among other things and not an
allocation that maximizes Revenue so
they want to reclaim as much of the tax
Gap as possible they also want to
minimize the no change rate so they
don't like it when they audit
individuals who do not actually owe
excess tax
um they also want to deter all taxpayers
for misreporting so even if you're not
getting audited you should be afraid
that you will be because they don't want
you to miss report on your taxes right
and it also has to respect two different
forms of a budget one is a number of
audits or a percentage of the population
budget because you have to have enough
IRS Auditors to do all the audits that
you want to do and if you do too many
audits that's not going to happen
um and then this is a little bit
slightly softer but still exists there's
also you have to stay within a dollar
budget audits cost money to do and you
can't do more expensive audits or more
audits than you have money within your
organization to do
um and then finally you also have to
respect some further institutional
constraints about pressures that
Congress have put on you to look into
certain kinds of taxpayers or
um certain kinds of rules about uh what
to look at um
when you're investigating tax returns
and on top of all of this I'm still
saying let's create an equitable system
that you know is Equitable as possible
with respect to income so seeing all of
this you know one response might be okay
let's make a crazy you know
multi-objective problem solve all of
this at once
um
but uh while there are some people at my
lab actually working on coming up with
like an optimal auditing procedure I
think it's a really hard question to
come up with a system that you know
takes into account all of these
constraints at once especially because
equity and deterrence are really hard to
formalize uh so what happens in practice
and how we're going to think about this
problem is a two-part process in one
part a machine learning model
um
predicts uh risk for misreporting and
then in the second part of the process
there's some policy informed heuristics
that take those predictions into an
actual audit allocation and I think it's
also useful to think about these things
beyond the fact that that's you know
largely what actually happens in
practice uh one central question in this
research project is you know how well do
um some more typical machine learning
fairness interventions work at
preventing uh bias and machine learning
models and for that we need our classic
like here's a classification model that
does a prediction and we can slap some
constraints so
useful for us so with all that being
said the super super simplified audit
problem uh is that we are going to
maximize the output of um we're going to
maximize that but a predicted value from
a machine learning model subject to a
budget so uh this is the predicted
probability of misreport if you're using
a classification model that's trained on
zero one outputs or if you're using a
regression model
um that's trained to predict the
expected amount of how much people owe
on their taxes the tax liability it
would be you know the sum of of those
outputs
um
such that the number of audits that you
do is less than your audit budget or the
percentage of audits that you do is less
than your audit budget so in this
situation we're using a budget as a
percentage of the population we use
0.644 percent uh because that is the
average audit rate between 2010 and
2014.
uh so thus after prediction just to make
things super clear and super simple what
this amounts to is that you have a
machine learning model you rank your
predictions in terms of raw output and
you take the top point zero six four
four percent and that is your audit
allocation all right sorry the the
constraint here is just on the number
about it or it could be weighted
your audit budget is just the number of
audits that you so yeah
yeah that's the way that we're starting
um but the way that we're evaluating our
allocations is by seeing a how much
revenue they produce how much is
reclaimed by the IRS and the no change
rate so the rate of auditing individuals
who do not actually owe
um more tax
uh does this make sense to everyone and
also of course vertical equity which I
will get to in a moment but deterrence
and all those other things a little bit
too complicated for now so we're just
basically saying we want High Revenue we
want a low rate of auditing people who
don't actually owe excess tax and we're
also going to think about uh fairness
exactly so again this is revenue not uh
this is net revenue it doesn't account
for the cost of Their audience so the
revenue calculation does actually take
into account the cost of their
[Music]
audience um so our goal here is to
increase Equity without decreasing
revenue and uh increasing the rate at
which individuals are audited to not
actually owe excess tax
um and of course we want to create
things uh create the allocation to be as
Fair as possible so I'm quickly going to
talk about how we think about fairness
in this context
um so uh what are our fairness does a
Dorada here uh to understand this
question we've borrowed this idea from
the Public Finance literature called
vertical equity which is centered around
the idea that in order to achieve
fairness you should acknowledge the
differences between individuals and
treat them appropriately differently in
order to achieve fairness and this is a
little bit from a little bit different
from a lot of the common definitions in
the fairness literature which I would
argue cluster sort of around this other
related idea that the Public Finance
literature calls horizontal equity which
is that we think of all people as equal
so we want to treat them the same all
the time so this leads to you know
equalizing rates demographic disparity
equalizer positive false positive rates
Etc
um so vertical Equity isn't a fairness
definition I don't have a definition up
on the slide it's more of a framework
from which we're thinking about how to
think about equity in this context and
it requires information about the actual
application to make sense and so how do
we make sense of it in this situation uh
well first you know we notice that
audits pose varying burdens on people
depending on their income so people with
less money might experience a higher
burden from having an IRS tax audit and
so we prefer slightly
um
we prefer allocations that decrease
audit focus on lower income individuals
so we want things to be kind of
monotonic we prefer more monotonicity in
our audit allocation
and a little bit more another way that
we're conceptualizing fairness here is
that we also want audit selection to
closely reflect the allocation of an
oracle where an oracle model in this
case is a model that knows
who misreported how much everyone
misreported and selects individuals in
terms in order of how much they
misreported on their taxes
um and how we're going to measure how
much the uh a given model's allocation
corresponds to that of the Oracle is we
just measure the overlap in their
allocation so how many people do they
audit in common over the total number of
audits
uh
the the calculation or so we we take the
absolute number of people that they have
in common and then we divide by the
total number of people in the audit
which is going to be the same size
the Oracle you said
related to the
amounts of what is that the absolute
amount of relatives yes
um
so now that we have this
um now that we sort of know how we're
thinking about fairness in this context
I can say finally what do we want we
want uh to increase vertical Equity
without uh hurting revenue and no change
rate so that means we want more
monotonic allocations that are close to
this notion of the Oracle with high
revenue and low no change
um does this make sense sorry listening
what does oracle mean is that like the
ground true that's the so that's the
model that um basically selects people
for audit in order of how much they're
non-compliant on their taxes so it's
like it's kind of like a ground truth
model but it's like a model that has
perfect knowledge yeah
is that like it's how how much they
extra money they owe the IRS one
violation it's the actual it's the
actual amount of money yeah
um no problem okay
so now I will get to the results that we
saw in this project so firstly
um you know the IRS was looking to get
into these more high power machine
learning models to use for audit
allocation so we used random forests on
um on the IRS tax data this is not what
they use on a day-to-day basis at least
not yet so don't worry this is not the
the models that they actually use
um but here we have the audit rate by
income of the allocation of a random
Forest classification model predicting
whether or not someone is likely to
misreport on their taxes so this model
is trained on binary outcomes and so on
the y-axis we have audit rate on the
x-axis we have income in thousands per
income decile where the income at the
lower end of the decile the black line
shows the audit rate by income of the
random forests uh Oracle the random
forests model allocation and then the
red line shows the allocation of that of
the Oracle and remember we're talking
about allocations here and not all of
the model's predictions so this is just
the distribution over the top point six
four four percent of predictions because
this is the Oracle this is the model's
allocation and not all of its prediction
so I'm not I'm not saying that this is
what like
every single person that the random
forest model selected for audit this is
just the top point six four four percent
which would be exactly who we would want
it it's about 1.25 million people does
that make sense
yes can you calculate the Oracle is it
so we have the true amount of money that
each person missed afforded in the NRP
data yes exactly
um so you know the no change rate on
this is pretty good uh it you know
doesn't audit virtually anyone who
doesn't misreport on their taxes it only
has a no change with about 3.5 percent
which is an increase from some of the
more simple model that the IRS had been
using earlier
um but it has a pretty big problem which
is that in this you know using this
model it pretty much only audits people
in the lower to Middle income classes
and doesn't Target people on the higher
end of the income Spectrum at all so to
fix this problem we first try to use
some off-the-shelf bias mitigation uh we
enforce equalized odds which in this
case is enforcing that across different
income bins so we bin incomes by the
percentiles that we've been seeing so
each income bin is 10 percentiles of the
population zero to ten is one then 10 to
20 is another Etc
um
we enforce equalized odds over the uh
income bins so we that that means that
we're enforcing that the probability
that a compliant or non-compliant tax
paper payer is subject to audit does not
depend on their income then and we
implement this with fairlearn from
Microsoft
um
and as an example of our results uh
consider this graph of auto rate by
income decile here it's the same X and Y
axis from before and we just have the
addition of this blue model which is an
equalized odds constrained random forest
classifier and we basically noticed
three things firstly is that
um because because we have a budgeted
allocation here we're only using the top
point six four four percent of the
model's predictions equalized odds while
it's satisfied on the whole population
as a result of using
um this method or post-processing
methods it's not satisfied on just this
portion of the population so equalized
odds uh isn't exactly satisfied here
um and you know but there is some
marginal Equity Improvement although it
is marginal uh there is you know some
focus on higher uh income populations
but not um a huge amount and definitely
still like a huge gap with relation to
the Oracle and as you can see the Oracle
overlap is uh only about four percent so
we increased by about four percent which
isn't maybe amazing given what we're
going for
um and finally what I'll note here is
that there are some pretty high
trade-offs so uh we decrease revenue
from 3 billion originally to 0.5 billion
so around 2.5 billion dollar decrease in
Revenue not leaving you with very much
uh and we also increased the no change
rate by about 10 so not not super
amazing uh in terms of yeah
thing uh High income individuals so like
at such a low rate like why utilize ads
make sense is the way to fix this or if
there's yeah so we because we were
saying earlier that like one of our
Notions of fairness was kind of like
monotonicity
um we showed that equalized odds under
the the
this under certain conditions will
enforce monotonicity in audit rate but
it's unclear how to enforce it over just
a portion of the population so we did it
over the whole population then it didn't
kind of like follow through
um so that was the reason why equalized
ads sort of made sense we also did some
other fairness metrics just you know for
I don't know completion's sake but this
is what I'm focusing on
your predictions
yes yes
the the amount of just whether zero one
everything is
whether or not they
so it's like were you non-compliant or
not okay
but what you're showing here so this is
the population of people that I am going
to audit because this is the top point
six four four percentage predictions
because we're taking the maximum uh raw
you know uh in this case the raw maximum
raw probability of this report based on
the random models random Force models
prediction so it's since it's predicting
zero one it's kind of like you know how
likely am I to have misreported on my
taxes
foreign
Forest to Output between zero and one
like how how close to one of the things
it is right so like it's trained on zero
one but there's a raw output between
you're using the rules exactly oh I see
okay yes but but post-processing for
equalized thoughts okay so this is in
processing we also have post-processing
and the results are effectively the same
we didn't do post-processing accounting
just for the six percent we did do okay
maybe it's somewhere in the paper but I
think the tricky thing no it's not the
tricky thing is there is like you have
to keep on going deeper into the
set to satisfy that so it's kind of
unclear how you would do it on just the
allocation if that makes sense like to
get to get equalized odds on just the
top point six four four percent since
you don't have the individuals to make
it satisfy equalizer you would have to
keep on pulling up from later and later
in the ranking and yeah
um yeah
yeah so I guess all right with two
questions one is
what would it look like instead of
trying to predict you think the audit
rate you try to predict the actual
amount that's what we're getting to and
then what about if you it kind of
enforce like calibration conditions that
are specific to just those pious
mid instead of like Snap maybe we can
talk about later but just in the
instance of time I'm about to get to
what you're saying yes
um because I also want to get to my
second paper hopefully
um so
exactly what you said so we didn't find
this to be extremely effective what can
we do instead we can change the model's
prediction task as an intervention to
um increase equity in this setting
so if we switch from training on zero
one labels whether or not someone has
just reported to their taxes to the
expect to the amount that they've
misreported on the taxes that the model
is now predicting the expected amount of
missed report we can see here already
this is a lot closer to the Oracle and
the focuses a lot more on the upper
income classes uh so this is the audit
rate by income of the audit allocation
of a random forest model that is
predicting the expected adjustments
um and so you know I don't have to dwell
too much about this basically it works a
lot better right the equity Improvement
is great has the largest
um Equity largest Oracle overlap up to
23 it's just about as monotonic as the
Oracle which is nice uh and it also has
lower trade-offs so we actually have a
seven billion dollar increase in Revenue
so now we're increasing we have a 10
billion dollar Revenue
um from this model where we only had
three billion dollars when we did the
the predicting on zero one labels before
and while we do have a steep decrease in
no change rate at least we are only
decreasing one metric instead of two so
the trade-offs here I would say are
better yeah
closer to the actual deploy system right
um yes so the IRS currently predicts on
zero one levels but as a result of some
of the work that we've been doing
they're switching to regression
which is a fun success story
how does a no change rate um um track
for income
yeah so it's much higher and the higher
income
um special one like the the rate of
auditing people who don't actually owe
access taxes much higher the higher
income you go and that's related to I
forget who was asking this question
earlier I think it was Charlotte why why
do we think the models are not targeting
High income individuals I think the
feature set that the IRS has access to
is abysmal for predicting
um non-compliance on high income
individuals and so you have just a whole
lot more uncertainty on the higher end
of the income Spectrum which is why even
though audit rate increases
monotonically in income you just don't
have the information to Target that part
of the population
um and what I'm working on now as a
follow-up is Building Systems
specifically designed for high wealth
tax evasion so that's like my follow-up
work
um
what's like what fraction of the
variance can you explain generally
that is a great question that I would
love to know the answer to and I should
probably do some research to answer
exactly that but I don't know
I just couldn't hear yeah oh I was just
asking like what's like the R square or
like the correct model
oh
I heard this like for this regression
problem that you should I
put that as in the paper somewhere but I
don't know
um so the takeaways here uh are you know
modeling changes Beyond just slapping a
constraint on top of a model during
prediction time or uh at during
optimization time
um
you know instead intervening at the
prediction Target or other places along
the pipeline can actually successfully
increase desired fairness behavior and
practice which is awesome because
sometimes those traditional approaches
don't often work super well out of the
box as we thought in this situation and
um I will note really quickly you know
you could say Emily good for you you
solved audits like you know does this
just fix the whole situation no it's a
little bit more complicated than that
and I'm happy to talk about that offline
but I definitely don't have time for it
right now
um so
um what if we can't take advantage of
all of that flexibility what if we can't
rebuild our whole model from sort of the
ground up well uh you know what if we
have our data source and prediction
Target kind of set and we have almost no
wiggle room to make allowances for
fairness with respect to accuracy well
what I'm going to talk about now is that
we still have a lot of flexibility to
uh increase fairness Behavior even when
we're keeping the model exactly as
accurate as it was before or like within
Epsilon and these constraints actually
make it a lot easier to connect
um uh to the law and increase legal
pressure on organizations to search for
the ferris model out there
um
so now I'm focusing on the situation
where we've already defined our
prediction task and perhaps we can't
sacrifice any performance change for
fairness but I was increasingly many
Works have shown there are still so many
models that have equivalent accuracy yet
differ substantially in other properties
like fairness but also robustness
interpretability among others
um this phenomenon has been called many
different things by many people over the
last several years so starting all the
way back in 2001 the rashmon effect by
uh Bremen or bryman I don't know how to
pronounce his name uh more recently
predictive multiplicity by Marx at all
leaving out unfairness by paper I had a
little bit a while ago and under
specification by DMR at all uh and you
know what my co-authors and I attempted
to do in this second work that I'm going
to talk to you about is to unify our
understanding of this phenomenon where
there are multiple equally accurate
models for the same task with noticeably
different behaviors
um uh give a little bit more detail on
how this arises and its technical legal
and policy consequences so we call this
phenomenon of multiple models existing
for the same prediction task model
multiplicity
um
and Under the Umbrella of this term we
break things up into procedural and
predictive multiplicity which I'll
Define and talk about in a minute
um I'll just note quickly that a lot of
the work in the fact Community sort of
implicitly takes advantage of this um uh
of this
phenomenon because the the mere goal of
saying I'm going to you know uh enforce
a fairness constraint on a model and
hope that it has minimal accuracy
trade-off or no accuracy trade-off is
implicitly taking advantage of the fact
that that this is happening um but maybe
we don't think about it as you know all
these possible models existing for the
same task as such
um and even though that's a great thing
that we can take advantage of there are
also risks posed by this phenomenon
namely if we have all these equally
accurate models that exist for the same
task that do differ in other behaviors
we can essentially be arbitrarily
choosing between models that have
sub-optimal fairness behaviors about
robustness Behavior or sub-optimal
predictions for individual people which
can lead to some fairness repercussions
there
um but first I'll start with some
definitions uh we have predictive
multiplicity which is when there are
differences in predictions between
equally accurate models so you have the
same person over different models with
the same accuracy leading to varying
predictions
um maybe this is already seeming kind of
like whoa uh there could be some
fairness problems here based on which
model you choose so I'll get into that
in a little bit
um more formally if you have
distribution D of data and you have X or
a pairs X Y from D
um and you have some distribution of
binary classification models M that have
more or less equivalent accuracy we
Define the predictive multiplicity over
M to be the expectation over different
models in M that the that their
prediction on two random points in D
will be different so the disagreement is
actually the expected disagreement over
model in m
um we also talk about procedural
multiplicity a lot in the paper this is
where there are differences in model
internals that don't get shown in
prediction so how we most often see this
is when there's inconsistency in model
explanations so even if you have the
same prediction if you ask a model why
did I get this prediction models with
the same accuracy might say like oh you
didn't get it because you're you didn't
get approved for credit because your
income wasn't high enough another one
will say it's because your credit
history wasn't long enough or whatever
it may be
um Ms can also lead to some
inconsistency
I'm not going to formalize this because
most of the results that I have
are centered around predictive
multiplicity so if you're interested in
this please read the paper for more
information
um
and I'll just briefly go through some
theoretical results around accuracy
variance and predictive multiplicity
um so you know you might think Emily why
are you worried about this obviously uh
the more accurate your models are the
less predictive multiplicity you're
going to have so we don't really have to
think about this very much at all and
then while some sense this is true
um as uh no mod to no two models can
disagree on a percentage of points
indeed that's over two times the model's
error so if the error of all the models
in m is L star you can't have more
disagreement than two l-star and we also
show that though I won't go into the
proof is that in the limit as the error
of our models approach the Bayes error
predictive multiplicity goes to zero
while all of this all of this is true so
it might seem like okay we don't really
have to worry about predicted
multiplicity because the more accurate
you get you know when you find your base
optimal model you don't have to think
about the fact that there are all these
different models with all these
different behaviors
um
but actually things are kind of more
complicated than this
um yeah
so yeah so
um no actually it doesn't have to be
zero it just has to be a predictable
problem so the base risk can't be such
that the you always get like um 50 50
here
um
I can show you the proof in the paper if
that works yeah
um things are a little bit more
complicated than this and to see why we
have to turn to the standard bias
variance decompositions of error we show
that multiplicity is tightly related to
variance and so any attempts to increase
accuracy by increasing variance as well
will actually lead to more model
multiplicity and not less obviously
until you get to like the the optimal
predictor
um and so to see this uh we create this
mode predictor over the model's M which
just Returns the most common prediction
over all of the models M we Define the
variance to be the expected difference
between the mode predictor and any given
model
um and what we show is that the model
multiplicity is bounded on both sides by
the variance and thus you know
increasing variance so it will increase
model multiplicity and specifically
reducing a model's loss by trading off
bias for variance and increasing the
model's variance will increase
predictive multiplicity
um
so uh you know while models with optimal
accuracy won't display predictive
multiplicity the road to improving
accuracy will often be paved with more
and more model multiplicity depending on
whether you're deploying more complex
models to achieve this and as we often
don't get optimal models in practice
this actually happens
um quite a lot of the time
and uh this does actually happen in
practice
um this is a quick example from
um a paper of mine a few years ago uh
basically we have deep models on the
left and then your models on the right
the accuracy increase of going from
linear to deep is over 10 but if we see
like this is a little bit complicated
but right here these this is the amount
of differences and predictions over
leave one out changes to a model's
training set in linear models and then
the blue is for deep and as we can see
even though these models are much more
accurate up here there's a lot more
differences in predictions so a lot more
predictive multiplicity
um uh
um in those deep models
so I'm going to start to close out my
talk
um with some opportunities concerns and
recommendations based on the fact that
mono multiplicity exists as I kind of
showed a little bit quickly in those
theoretical results we can't just expect
that model multiplicity is going to go
away with increased accuracy we do
actually have to
grapple with the fact that there are
multiple equally accurate models for any
given prediction task
um so there are some nice things about
this we have a lot more flexibility than
we maybe originally think about to take
advantage of models um to find and then
use models that have the best fairness
Behavior among those that are equally
accurate
um
and we can do this not just for
predictions but also for models
internals we can build models
specifically with the behavior in mind
of having there be for example more
easily attainable recourse so having you
know an accredited uh credit allocation
model you can prefer models that have an
easier path for someone to be able to
change their prediction to get a good
outcome after getting a bad one
um
and interestingly this is where one of
the places where a legal connection
comes in so the fact that there are so
many equally accurate models with
different fairness Behavior it can lead
to
um legal pressure to search for and
choose the most Fair model so this is
based on the disparate impact Doctrine
so the disparate impact Doctrine is a
piece of law that says it applies to
credit housing and employment context
among some others and it says that if
you you know are an organization and
you're using a model or any other
decision process that I'm talking about
models here that model can only treat
individuals of different demographic
groups differently if they're if the
business can demonstrate a legitimate
business need
to have this disparate impact across
groups right
um and in practice this legitimate
business need is often understood to
mean that you need to have that
disparate impact in order to get the
accuracy that your model is presenting
and so what model multiplicity shows is
that even if you know even if the
business doesn't want to give up
anything in terms of accuracy there is
probably still a better model out there
that has better fairness Behavior if
they weren't you know explicitly looking
for that
um and so there can be legal pressure to
sort of search among the space of models
that are
um equally
effective to the one that you have and
find the best one with respect to
fairness in this case this would
probably be demographic disparity
because that's often what's focused on
in these um legal
um of course the flip side and this is
why the legal pressure is necessary is
that if you don't specifically look for
fairer models you're probably going to
end up with one that isn't the best
um I'm going to skip this for now
um
finally I think yeah this is my last
sort of idea
um a nice thing about having many
similar models with slightly different
predictions is that it can be a natural
bulwark against algorithmic monoculture
which is the fear that all companies in
the same area so like all algorithmic
hiring models will use a very similar
model to base their to to use in their
company and so when they use the same or
similar model they'll get all the same
predictions and they'll systematically
exclude certain individuals and we can
see since even like tiny changes to a
model's building process can lead to a
substantial number of different
predictions this um
this may not be as huge of a of a
concern as we might think or at least in
some cases it won't be
um of course the flip side of that is
that uh there is sort of a lack of
justifiability in the current de facto
um process for choosing which model to
use if we choose models on the basis of
accuracy alone uh that is sort of akin
to choosing between very disparate
outcomes for individuals with no real
justification because bohobi's models
performed equally well so for the for
the businesses perspective you could
have used either of them but for this
individual it had very different
outcomes and so model multiplicity
brings attention to the fact that in
order to fully justify model decisions
and procedures in high-stakes contexts
we have to justify the choice of model
as well as the model's internal decision
process
um and uh
some even yeah this might not seem like
oh it's a random Choice it's not that
bad and I want to distinguish between
arbitrariness and random here so I'm
borrowing from uh this paper May the
odds ever be in your favorite lotteries
in law by Perry and zarsky and they say
the the decision to opt for chance must
be reasoned so you can have an arbitrary
decision an arbitrary decision is one
that's made without thought you don't
know that you're making a choice between
these two disparate outcomes for a given
person but you can choose for that
decision to be random for some you know
legitimate reason and that can be a fine
thing so what we're trying to get rid of
is arbitrariness and not randomness
um there is a lot of writing in the law
about how arbitraryness is undesirable
from the Fair Credit Reporting Act and
the Equal Credit Opportunity Act they
have a lot of sort of language about how
there shouldn't be arbitrary decisions
in high-stakes applications like Credit
Credit scoring and credit allocation
um so we think that you know this might
carry over to have some impact on
um how we should select models and these
uh applications given that there's this
legal language that says that
arbitrariness is bad but there isn't
anything in like the exact letter of the
law that says that you have to justify
the model selection process at the
moment just the explanation within the
model although a growing number of legal
Scholars are making the argument that in
order to fully justify a model's
decision you shouldn't just justify why
that particular model made a given
decision but also why that model was
chosen in the first place and to sort of
um add to that justification we
basically recommend documenting why
you've made every single Choice along
this Pipeline and between that
justification of how you got to the
model that you arrive at plus the
model's decision justification will
justify
um why you have a given prediction for a
given individual
and uh even if you do all of these
things you're probably still going to
have a bunch of models that satisfy all
of the things that you want from a given
application and if that's the case you
can aggregate if you still okay so
sometimes you might want Randomness
because you want to prevent algorithmic
monoculture or something along those
lines but in other cases
um you
might actually just want one prediction
one non-random prediction from uh
uh for a given application like say in
criminal justice proceedings or um other
super high stakes uh situations and in
that case you can just combine the
outputs of a bunch of models that
satisfy all of the things that you want
them to satisfy fairness and accuracy or
whatever they may be
um maybe perhaps I'm taking the mode
prediction and reaching a more stable
output and I have a paper on how to
reach stability by doing this called
selective ensembling for a consistent
prediction so if we're going to look
into that if you're interested in that
idea
um but
um that brings me to the end of this
talk and what I hope that you took away
from this is that the AI pipeline can
expand our toolbox of bias mitigation
techniques we saw this in the IRS case
study we can leverage you know a lot of
the choices that we make along the model
building pipeline to enforce fairness in
different
um real world applications and uh also
that the choices along the AI pipeline
have important policy and legal
implications so even the fact that we
have so many equally accurate models or
really models in general for the same
prediction task means that we have to
think carefully about why we're making
each choice along the model building
process we should be able to justify
that choice and hopefully document that
choice
um and if we choose models that are not
the fairest in certain situations uh you
know if we're at a big company we might
be liable for not choosing that
particular model
um yeah that's my talk thank you so much
guys
[Applause]
which which have like for every Dynamic
state
right right
yeah but so if you're I think the point
that we're trying to make here is that
if you're cognizant that that's a choice
that you're making and you've decided
that that's better for your application
um context then that's fine you can
choose to be random that's great what
we're trying to prevent against here is
that someone essentially you know is
trying to make a credit
um allocation or a loan allocation model
we're like all right I'm just going to
choose the most accurate one not knowing
that you know there are a like
infinitely many models that satisfy that
criteria there's this whole set of
models that are equally accurate and
that if you looked within them you could
find models that are much more fair or
much more robust
um or have other properties that they
may desire and they're just not taking
advantage of that flexibility at all so
it's more the thoughtlessness that we're
trying to go against and the fact that
people I think often just think like
okay optimize optimize for my
um optimization criteria and I just
assume that I'm going to get the optimal
model but really we don't often get the
Apple model in practice and when we're
not at the Apple model we're in this
situation where we have this kind of
whole pool of models that we are equally
effective and we should be reasoning
among why we choose one over another
within that side
that makes sense yeah
thank you